here are some other corporate emails
that mistakenly got sent out this is
unfortunately Walgreens emailed for when
CVS is too far of a drive yeah
zillow.com emailed fixer-uppers you can
start your meth business in today Wow
opentable comm emailed based on your
recent dining history here are some
great deals on Big & Tall menswear these
are real by the way you can FedEx
emailed fYI it's illegal to send weed
but to be honest we don't have the
manpower to do much about it Warby
Parker comm email try our new collection
of frames that will make you look poor
and smart Volkswagen emailed not all of
Hitler's ideas were bad egg
let's folks wagon that's not on us
Bulger's let's get the car started Andy
Folgers emailed Lee heard that you think
Folgers really is the best part of
waking up and that's sad here's a coupon
and finally Fandango emailed our seat
selection tools help you find the best
seats for Master P
[Applause]
why why why did they send us no but he
knows it's the back corner you need help
knowing that what and dad I didn't want
to know what movie you are seeing
[Laughter]
you